Das Podcast-Dufo ist ein Podcast mit Florian Tietze, mit Stefan Tietze, mit Stefan Tietze. Da Brücke ich doch wollte, da Brücke mit dem Willen, mit der Bitte. Mit Stefan Tietze, Blauwegeil, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte, bitte,. Für alle, die immer noch auf Etienne Gardet warten, das wird dieses Jahr wahrscheinlich nichts mehr.
Ihr seit Folge 86 klammert ihr euch an diesem Podcast in der Hoffnung, noch mal einen Hauch Gardet zu verspüren. Er wird nicht kommen, wir müssen euch hier leider enttäuschen. Was ihr allerdings stattdessen bekommt, ist ein fantastisches Intro von Mike. Mikey! Wie schreibt man Mike? M-I-C? Nein, er hat das Mike nicht gedroppt, sondern er hat einen heißen Banger gedroppt. Vielen, vielen Dank an Mike für dieses tolle Intro. Das ist eine unangenehme Stille, die du da kurz hast ausbreiten wollen. Vielen Dank an Mikey für das Intro, es ist kalt. Es ist kalt, wir sitzen immer noch in unserer kleinen Kombüse eiskalt. Stefan hat extra seine Wärmeohrringe angezogen. Das Startup, das er vor zwei Jahren gegründet hat, diese Ohrringe mit diesem Knickmechanismus drin, die dann die Ohren wärmen. Es hat sich nicht durchgesetzt, er selber hat auch schwere Brandwunden an den Ohren, aber er zieht es halt durch. Kochen heiß wurde es. Er zieht es als Geschäftsführer einfach durch. Ich fühle mich gerade wie Bernie Sanders bei dieser Inauguration, wie der da saß, mit dieser dicken Jacke und diesen dicken Handschuhen, die sind Fäustlingen auch. Grosser Fan bin ich ja von Fäustlingen. Ja, grossartig. Weil wer braucht Finger? Im Endeffekt braucht man doch einfach diese Lego-Zangen. Das reicht ja schon auch aus. Beine überschlagen, dicke Anorak an, und jetzt guck ich mal, lass mich mal ein bisschen berieseln, was so kommt. Ja, mit diesem Gesichtsausdruck, ich hab schon Lust, hier zu sein, aber die Kälte macht es mir unmöglich, mich zu freuen. Genau. So dieses, es wär schön, wenn's nicht so kalt wär, Blick. Es wär besser, es wär erträglicher, wenn's nicht so kalt wär. Aber hast du diese Knickpolster, diese kleinen ... Nicht mehr da, ich hatte sie früher mal. Du hast sie nicht mehr in petto. Ich hab sie nicht mehr in petto. Früher gab's sie ja mal, ich war sie ein bisschen verbreitet. Ich glaub, es war so diese Zeit, wo ich noch zur Schule ging. Da hat man sich plötzlich, da hatte man diese Wärmekissen und das war ja quasi so ein Gel, so ein Gel. Das war so ein kleiner Fusionsreaktor. So eine gallartige Masse, so neongrün geleuchtet, so wie diese Homer Simpson Neon-Dinger halt, die er durchs Intro schmeißt. Und da war ja so ein kleiner Chip drin. Und bis heute habe ich keine Ahnung, wie das funktioniert. Niemand versteht, wie das funktioniert. Man knickt diesen Chip und dann friert das ein und wird kochen heiß. Ja, niemand, das ist wahrscheinlich auch so Einhorn-Rückenmark oder so Nashorn-Rückenmark, was da drin ist. Niemand versteht, was das ist, aber hauptsächlich die achtjährigen Kinder haben warme Pfoten. Schön, wenn sie auf dem Bus warten. Ja, vor allem ja auch nicht. Also man benutzt es ja glaube ich auch noch falsch. Man guckt sich ja an, wie das funktioniert, anstatt es dazu zu benutzen, wenn ich actually die Hände zu wärmen. Du hast es in der Hand und bist zu fasziniert. Das ist das Problem. Das ist das Problem. Deswegen glaube ich, niemand benutzt es dafür. Weil das ist dann irgendwie der Zweck, ist dann irgendwie Quatsch, weil es zu cool ist.
Also der Weg, wie es wärmt, ist zu cool, als dass es wirklich zum Wärmen benutzt.
Das ist so, wie wenn du einen Salzstreuer hast, der zu fancy aussieht und die Leute zu viel Salz benutzen, weil sie immer wieder diesen Salzstreuer ...
Am Ende kontraproduktiv.
Kontraproduktiv, alles, du hast dir Mühe gegeben, du standst stundenlang in der Küche und hast dir aber leider so einen Designersalzstreuer geholt, der einfach ergonomisch ist, der sich an die Hand anschmiegt, tolle, feine Grafit-Oberfläche. Und unten noch so Licht macht. Ja genau, nur wenn du ihn in der Hand hast, fängt er schon an zu malen, das Mehrsalz. Und du denkst einfach, boah geil, und einfach irgendwie der technikaffine Onkel salzt sich sein Essen in Himalaya rein, einfach weil er den Salzstreuer so gerne mag. Pfeffer dasselbe so und dann versucht man ja dagegen zu steuern mit Salz und Pfeffer und hat beide Pole in der Hand und es macht es immer noch schlimmer. Und dann cut, man verabschiedet sich und dann geht die Tür zu und man dreht sich um und guckt sich die Wohnung an und die ist komplett weiss. Weisse Wohnung, weil alle diesen Streuer in der Hand haben, die Kontrolle über diesen Salzstreuer verloren haben. Wir sehen einen Salzengel, den noch ein Kind reingemalt hat in dieses ganze Salz. Aber es ist einfach zu cool. Es ist einfach zu cool. Kennst du das, wenn man seine Gäste verabschiedet? Kennst du bestimmt. Und dann macht man die Tür... Halbes Rotweiglas in der Hand, die Zigarre raucht noch ein bisschen. Genau, machst die Tür... Aber der Abend neigt sich dem Ende. Richtig, alle gehen raus und verabschieden sich noch, ein paar Gags werden hinterhergerufen, die Tür fällt in Schloss stille. Oder vielleicht nicht ganz stille, vielleicht läuft noch die Playlist, die man angemacht hat. Michael Bublé schweigt nie. Vielleicht sinkt Michael Bublé noch durch deine Halle in hell an der Wohnung. Und du drehst dich um und mit so einem seligen Seufz da, aber so einem leichten Grinsen auf den Nippen. Und vor allem mit dem Gedanken, ich räume morgen auf. Nee, das machen wir morgen in Ruhe. Weißt du, Schatz, Schatz, lass die Gläser stehen, das machen wir morgen. Die Freundin, die besoffen über dem Tisch hängt, Schatz, das machen wir morgen in Ruhe, komm. Und sie auch so, ja komm, wir gehen jetzt ins Bett. Es ist interessant, ich habe die Situation noch nie erlebt, aber sie wirkt vertraut. Sie will nie... Aber ich habe sie noch nie erlebt. Nee, und ich bin da noch immer genervt eher, warum sind die nicht schon vor drei Stunden gegangen? Der Abend war schon vor drei Stunden vorbei. Jetzt hat er seinen Schal liegen gelassen. Heinrich! Heinrich! Er hört mich nicht. Schreib ihm doch eine Nachricht. Heinrich, jetzt sitzen sie im Auto. Jetzt sitzen sie im Auto. Ach. Taxi ist auch schon da. So läuft das doch normalerweise. Dieser eine Gast, der die ganzen Abend
Side-Talks angefangen hat,
so komische Gespräche,
während man mit mir spricht, fängt dann an,
die Person, die neben einem Seite,
Side-Talks anzufangen. Ich hab dir gesagt, wir hätten die nicht
neben Franz setzen sollen. Die haben die ganze Zeit
über die Diagonale geredet, die ganze Zeit.
War das doch jetzt nicht.
Die haben die ganze Zeit über Bertram geredet,
der da die Unbeteiligte dagegen sass, die haben über Diagonale
über ihn drüber geredet. Der Trutern wurde gar nicht beachtet.
Die Creme Brûlée wurde gar nicht angefasst.
Aber dann auch noch schön das, was die anderen übrig gelassen haben, weg snacken. Das ist auch noch schön. In der Küche und dann während der eine sich schon duscht, snackt der andere noch in der Küche die Creme Brûlée weg. Was mich nervt ist, ich habe viel zu wenig Geschirr, weil ich habe sehr viel Geschirr, es sieht zumindest viel aus, aber wenn man dann erstmal ein paar Gäste da hat, viel hat man sehr wenig Geschirr. Der Grund, warum ich mir diese ganzen Gedanken auch mache, ist, weil dieses Weihnachten zum ersten Mal alle Verwandten zu mir kommen nach Köln. Meine ganze Ruhrpott-Verwandten-Clique kommt Weihnachten am 24. zu mir abends. Ich habe gestern erst mal einen Weihnachtsbaum gekauft.
Ich habe noch nie mehr im Leben für meine Wohnung. Alter, Stefan, du bist erwachsen, herzlichen Glückwunsch.
Du bist erwachsen, das ist wirklich der Moment, wo niemand mehr sagen kann, du darfst nicht in der Achterbahn mitfahren, du bist zu klein, du darfst den Film nicht schauen.
Du kannst sagen, ich habe schon mal einen Weihnachtsbaum gekauft.
Nee, mir wird gesagt, du bist zu groß wie die Achterbahn.
So erwachsen bin ich jetzt geworden.
Es schlägt schon wieder rum.
Es ist direkt umgeschlagen. Ich habe gestern losgegangen, habe mir einen Weihnachtsbaum gekauft und da fängt es schon an. Nimmt man den Klassiker, die Nordmann-Tanne. Nein, weiß ich nicht. Oder was exotisch ist, eine Palme, Weihnachtspalme. Weihnachtspalme. Warum nicht? Christmas-Palme. Ich habe mich dann für einen schönen Tannenbaum aus Olpe entschieden, weil dieser Tannenbaumverkauf war nun mal aus Olpe, war regional, die waren irgendwie, die wachsen dann natürlich und dann haben die die abgeschlagen und dann haben die dahingestellt. Und ich habe gesagt, komm, schlage ich zu. Und hast du auch diese Netzkanone benutzt, wo der Weihnachtsbaum dann einmal da durchgeschossen wird? Ich nicht, der Weihnachtsbaumverkäufer hat die da durchgeballert. Ich hätte da drauf bestanden, dass ich die selber benutzen will. Diese Weihnachtsbaumkanone, wo das so eingenetzt wird. Ja, das habe ich auch schon ein paar Mal gemacht. Es ist ja nicht mein erster Weihnachtsbaumkauf gewesen, es war mein erster Weihnachtsbaumkauf für meine Wohnung. Ah, kennt sich aus, ein Kenner. Und jetzt hat komischerweise in Köln, was ich nicht verstehe, auf dieser klassischen, nervigen, mainstream, überbevölkerten Einkaufsstraße der Schildergasse hat ein Weihnachtsladen aufgemacht. Über drei Stockwerke heißt der It's all about Christmas. Und weil ich dachte, ich will coole Kugeln haben. Ich will, weil ich bin auch, ich bin nach ästhetischen Anspruch an meinen Weihnachtsbaum, der soll coole Kugeln haben. Ich will nicht diese Klassiker, Teddy, roten Dinger haben. Nein, ich will was Schickes haben. Sondern dann habe ich diesen Weihnachtsladen entdeckt und dachte mir,
perfekt, das ist ja die perfekte Antwort auf alle meine Fragen. Und dann bin ich reingegangen und es war die geballte, weil wir haben schon mal darüber gesprochen, wir lieben ja Bedarfshandlungen. Wir lieben, waren wir schon mal Angeln? Nein, lieben wir Angelbedarfshandlungen? Ja, man liebt diese super nischige Fokussierung auf diese eine Sache, lieben wir ja. Ich will 30 verschiedene Haken sehen, die sich ganz minimal unterscheiden.
Und ich will da sehr viel Geld erlassen und weiß, dann packe ich diese Angel in meinen Vorratsschrank und werde die nie wieder benutzen. Egal. Aber und dann dachte ich mir, okay, ich brauche für meinen Tannenbaum, den ich jetzt gekauft habe, brauche ich eine Lichterkette, ich brauche geile Kugeln, Lametta, so und vielleicht brauche ich ein bisschen Deko für die Wohnung, damit die Leute sich heimelig fühlen, weihnachtlich fühlen. Dann gehe ich in diesen Laden und auf drei Stockwerken hast du alles, alle Farben. Und damit meine ich nicht nur, du hast grüne Kugeln, nein, du hast Mintgrün, du hast leicht ins Ocker ragende Grün, du hast Graugrün, du hast Knallgrün, du hast Knallgrün glänzend, du hast Knallgrün matt, du hast Grün mit roten Punkten, du hast alle Farben und auf drei Stockwerken hast du wirklich nur Kugeln und Weihnachtsbedarf. Und ich bin am Ende wieder rausgegangen, weil ich mich nicht entscheiden konnte. Ja, am Ende hast du die Todesstern-Weihnachtskugel genommen, weil du gemerkt hast, ich bin noch ein kleiner Nerd. Ich bin doch noch ein kleiner Junge. Ich nehme einmal den Schnatz und dreimal den Todesstern, bitte. Aber das ist schon krass, da bist du schon echt weit gekommen.
Aber ich bin fasziniert von diesem Weihnachtsladen.
Ist dann den Rest des Jahres da Eiscreme drin oder kann man da auch reingehen und sagen, ich hätte gerne irgendwie einen Osterhasen und der guckt dich an mit so einem, den Gag hören wir einmal pro Stunde.
Ja, oder die bleiben einfach knallhart und sind auch im fucking Hochsommer ein Weihnachtsladen.
Ja, das fände ich Commitment.
Ziehen das einfach durch.
Das fände ich Commitment. Aber ich glaube einfach durch. Das fände ich Commitment.
Aber ich glaube, es ist noch... Und auch nicht runtergesetzt oder so.
Nee, nee, nee, noch teurer. Teurer.
Wer im Sommer Lametta
kaufen will, der muss richtig blechen. Der wird
richtig zur Kasse gebeten. Und dann
wurde aber alles trotzdem sommerlich geschmückt.
Es ist alles immer noch ein Weihnachtsladen,
aber du hast dann so einen Liegestuhl mit Lametta
drauf. Und der Weihnachtsmann hat eine Sonnenbrille auf.
Hat eine Sonnenbrille auf.
Und da liegt dann so ein Liegestuhl, wo dann Schnee drüber gestolpt ist. Weißt du? Ja, ja, ja, ich verschicke. Es ist ein bisschen sommerlich. Ja, ja, klar. Aber was mich einfach daran stört, es ist halt nicht Commitment, es ist auch kein saisonaler Laden, heißt, dass der im Sommer irgendwie anfängt, Pinacolada-Gläse zu verkaufen und Liegestühle, nein der ist dann weg. Der hat kein Commitment, dieser Laden, der ist einfach, das ist ein Pop-Up-Store, den gibt es nur wahrscheinlich bis Weihnachten und dann macht er wieder zu und dann kommt da was anderes rein, das ist also so wie so ein großer Lehrer, lehrstührender Laden, wo halt immer was anderes reinkommt. Ich finde es schade, ich finde, sei wenn ein Saisongeschäft und mache immer quasi, mache Frühling, Sommer, Herbst, Weihnachten artige Sachen und mach Osterdeko, mach Pfingstdeko. Ja eben, es könnte ein Feiertagsladen sein, wo einfach immer der aktuelle Feiertag drin ist, Ostergeschäft, jetzt kommt Pfingsten um die Ecke, wir brauchen den Pfingstbrauch, Pfingststuhl und was man halt da alles braucht. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Ich kenne ja auch, ich kenne einen gewissen Freundeskreis, der irgendwann beschlossen hat, irgendwie zu wenig Feiertage. Wir feiern gern, wir dekorieren gern, wir schenken gern, aber irgendwie reicht uns nicht. Nee, reicht uns nicht. Und die haben eingeführt den Halbfeiertag. Das heißt, die feiern immer, also die feiern Weihnachten, aber sechs Monate danach feiern sie nochmal Halbweihnachten. Und auch Geburtstage gibt es immer den Halbgeburtstag nach sechs Monaten. Sourtstag, nach sechs Monaten. Halb Pfingsten, also die haben einfach alle Feiertage verdoppelt und auf die gegenüberliegende Seite des Globus gelegt und feiern das jetzt alles doppelt. Und da ist dann natürlich die gute Möglichkeit zu sagen, weil die feiern dann mitten im Sommer, auch nochmal Weihnachten, zu sagen, die können dann direkt einkaufen und haben dann irgendwie ihren Eierlikör dann schön in so einem Sangria-Eimer drin oder irgendwie sowas, je nachdem. Und das ist eigentlich eine gute Idee, aber als ich das gehört habe, dachte ich mir, meine Herren, zum Glück bin ich nicht in diesem Freundeskreis. Dieser eine Geburtstag im Jahr macht mich schon fertig und das alles doppelt, nee. Anstrengend, das liegt dann mit anstrengend in dem Freundeskreis der Welt. Ja, ganz furchtbar, ständig, aber das ist halt so. Diese Dinge, die man angeblich mag, machen sie dann doppelt so anstrengend, vor allem auch zweimal Silvester und solche Sachen. Das ist so ein sektenartiges Ding. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, die machen nichts anderes, als immer, wenn ich mit denen spreche, so, ja, ich bastle ja jetzt gerade wieder eine Karte und wir bereiten ja vor. Also die machen nichts anderes, als immer wieder auf den nächsten Feiertag hinzuhangeln und die denken sich auch welche aus, wenn man sagt, ah, mit zwei Monaten nichts, denken wir uns irgendwas aus. Finde ich gut, aber eigentlich finde ich es gut, die Idee, ja, praxisanschränkt, as fuck. Ja, absolut. Und es ist ja nichts Besonderes mehr, es ist halt einfach, gehört da normal dazu. Ich bin jetzt auch schon überfordert. So ist ja wie die alte Frage, würdest du lieber nie wieder Weihnachten feiern oder jeden Tag für den Rest deines Lebens? Nie wieder. Ja, ganz einfach. Das ist sehr einfach. Das ist diese alte Frage, die von Plato formulierte Granit gemeißelte Frage, die jetzt endlich, heute um 12.36 Uhr beantwortet werden konnte. Endlich. Das hat lange gedauert, ich habe viele Berechnungen durchgeführt und bin zum Gegensatz gekommen, nie wieder. Danke, endlich können wir die abhaken. Ja. Endlich mal wirklich mal was schaffen. Ne, und jetzt habe ich dann diesen nackten Tannenbaum in meiner Wohnung noch stehen. Ja. Und ich weiß nicht, also man muss ihn noch gießen, das war mir auch ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen neu, aber man muss da Wasser reinmachen.
Und hast du so einen Ständer?
Klar, Ständer habe ich schon besorgt, gestern auch noch im Baumarkt.
Wow.
Also jetzt bin ich erwachsen geworden, es fehlen noch die Kugeln und die Lichterketten.
Bei Lichterketten ist da die ganz alte Frage auch, die hat auch ein paar schon gestellt, nämlich nimmt man die Lichterkette, eine LED-Lichterkette oder nimmt man diese Kerzen, diese LED-Kerzen, die man so dran klemmt, die ich ja eigentlich schöner finde, punktuelle und eigentlich, ich habe mich gestern, stand ich in diesem Laden und nicht nur gab es beides, es gab beides in achtmal und acht verschiedenen Weißtönen, warmweiss, grelles, Ekelweiss, wo ich auch immer denke, alle haben sich auf warmweiss geeinigt, als ist das einzig Ansprechende. Warum gibt es noch das andere, warum gibt es noch dieses Neon-OP-Lichtweiss, was man kaufen kann? Ja, das ist das Erste, was man lernt. Weiss ist nie ganz weiss und schwarz ist nie ganz schwarz. Die erste Regel von Grafikdesign, wenn du was Weisses machen willst, mach es ein leichtes Stück grauer. Mach nie das weisseste weiss und mach nie das schwarzeste schwarz. Sonst sieht es komisch aus, sonst sieht es so defaultmäßig aus. Aber ich kann mich noch erinnern, richtig oldschool, Weihnachten bei Oma mit tatsächlich echten brennenden Kerzen, wo ich immer dachte, wir haben einen Baum mit brennenden Kerzen und wir haben eine Katze. Und Wunderkerzen brennen und glitzern an diesem Weihnachtsbaum. Ich beobachte das mal aus einer sicheren Distanz und wir schauen mal, was passiert. Aber es ist nie was passiert. Hat die Katze Angst vor Flammen vielleicht? Die haben Angst vor Feuer. Ja, die hat sich halt auch hauptsächlich ums Fondue beschäftigt. Und wir haben so ein bisschen Fleisch eingepackt in Geschenkpapier und unter einen Baum gelegt, dann konnte die das suchen. Dann hatte die auch ein kleines Geschenk bekommen. Also er hat die aktiv in Richtung Baum gelockt. In Kundenschule, ja. Aber die kriegt auch ein kleines Geschenk, ist doch klar. Aber ich glaube auch, dass ... Ja, weg von den brennenden Flammen. Ich glaube, bei Sicherheit gibt es eh so einen Kipppunkt. Wenn du wirklich dir zu wenig Mühe gibst für Sicherheit, wird es auch wieder sicher. Wenn es so offensichtlich gefährlich ist, dann reissen sich die Leute auch zusammen. Wenn du offensichtlich Flammen im Raum hast, am Baum, dann ist es wieder sehr sicher. Du meinst, jemand hat dann schon ein Auge drauf. Jemand hat dann schon ein Auge drauf. Wenn etwas so lächerlich gefährlich ist.
Bei meiner steht das vor einer Holzwand.
Es ist natürlich einfach eine Holzwand.
Davor steht der Baum.
Der Boden ist auch Holz.
Teppichboden. Teppichboden drunter. Darunter so eine polyamorien, wie heißt das, einfach so eine plastikartige Decke, die auch schön schnell Feuer fängt. Ja, mein Bruder hat sich einen Kanister Benzin gewünscht zu Weihnachten. So was. Verpackt unterm Baum. Genau, und jetzt hänge ich noch den echten Kerzen dran.
Und dann meinst du, einer meiner Verwandten wird schon, daneben wird auch noch nicht geraucht an dem Fenster. Aber du meinst, weil es alles so lächerlich gefährlich ist, jemand wird gucken. Es ist nicht mehr zu übersehen. Ich glaube, Sicherheit kann ja auch ein falsches Gefühl von Sicherheit geben, wenn man so hat, ah, das sind diese Lampen, da wird schon nichts passieren. Die lässt man dann mal über Nacht an und dann fangen die durch ein Kutschluss Femme oder keine Ahnung. Aber niemand lässt über Nacht brennende Flammen an, weil man einfach offensichtlich weiß, es ist zu gefährlich. Ich glaube, Sicherheit ist gefährlicher als Gefahr. Ich glaube, das ist so eine umgedrehte x hoch zwei Gleichung. Nee, es ist sogar einfach eine, der Graf dafür.
Warum gräbst du dir immer diese diese sag doch einfach eine U oder eine Kurve oder so, aber du gehst immer voll Nee, nee, wir müssen ja hier exponentiell denken, mein Freund. Du gehst wie so Stabhochspringer, du nimmst dir den längsten Stab in der Turnhalle, wo du sagst, erste Stabhochsprung. Machen sie direkt auf neun Meter. Wollen wir nicht mehr erstmal anfangen ohne Stab? Nee, hoch. Und du nimmst dir den längsten Stab und die höchste Latte und du rennst an und man denkt sich, das wird doch nichts. Das wird nichts. Und du jedes Mal fällst da hin. X hoch zwei, Y gleich F von X ist gleich Y gleich X Quadrat, ist nämlich das U-förmige, ja, ja, okay, alles klar, am Gebengehen, dieses Ding. Und worüber haben wir gesprochen? Unten ist am unsichersten. Ich glaube, diese Mitte, diese scheinbare Sicherheits. Ich glaube, wenn man sehr viel darauf achtet. Ich dachte, oben ist unsicher. Pass mal auf. Wenn man... Oben ist sicher, unten ist unsicher jetzt bei diesem Beispiel. Unten die X-Achse. Also in der Mitte des Us ist es besonders unsicher. Richtig. Wir können es doch einmal umdrehen, aber dann weiss ich nicht mehr, wie der Graph heißt. Ich meine nur, wenn man sehr, sehr viel Wert auf Sicherheit legt, glaube ich nicht daran, dass was passieren wird. Deswegen meine ich, maximal sicher. Dann, und dann kommt man
in diese Death Zone, diese
scheinbare Sicherheit, dieses man gibt
sich schon irgendwie Mühe damit
und so, und dann kommen nämlich diese Brände
von diesen LDD-Lammern, mit denen man gerechnet hat.
Und dann ganz hinten ist wieder maximal sicher,
weil je unsicherer alles ist,
desto mehr werden Leute aufachten.
Es gibt aber auch Statistiken,
dass zum Beispiel Fahrradfahrer
mit Helm, glaube ich, häufiger
in Unfälle verwickelt werden, weil
... desto mehr werden Leute aufachten. Es gibt aber auch Statistiken, dass zum Beispiel Fahrradfahrer mit Helm, glaube ich, häufiger in Unfälle verwickelt werden, weil die Autofahrer rundherum fahrlässiger fahren, weil sie denken, er hat einen Helm. Und weil der Fahrradfahrer fahrlässiger fährt, weil er mit dem Helm. Genau, weil er denkt, ich habe einen Helm. So wohingegen, wenn du da deine Rübe irgendwie völlig ungeschützt da den Naturgewalten aussetzt, du dir denkst, holy fuck, ich darf nicht stürzen und der Autofahrer denkt, holy fuck, ich darf dir nicht rammen, sonst passiert was Schlimmes und wohingegen
ohnehin der Mario-Kart-Reflex, immer wenn du
diese Helme siehst und schnell unterwegs bist,
dann sammelst du die ein, so, das gehört dazu.
Deswegen, ich glaube, mathematisch
hast du recht, empirisch habe ich recht.
Wir haben übrigens auch, die Empirie hat uns
neue
Dinge zugespielt und zwar zum
guten alten Thema, Weihnachten ist ja die Zeit der Träume und Kindheitsträume, die aber vernichtet werden, regelmäßig und einer unserer Es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr,, wir haben ein bisschen gesammelt, weil die schlechten Nachrichten hageln leider auf uns ein, sie schneien uns zu. Und würden wir das immer tagesaktuell
berichten, den Niedergang
der Coolness des T-Rex, so kämen wir
nicht hinterher. Es wäre ein eigener Podcast.
Im Grunde müssten wir
einen eigenen Podcast auslagern,
aber das wird nicht
funktionieren, deswegen hier mal ganz kurz,
einfach nur kurz und schmerzlos. Stefan,
ich mach's so schmerzlos, wie es geht.
Mach mal schnell. Wir müssen da jetzt wirklich schnell durch.
Schlagzeile eins, T-Rex hat Zahnschmerzen.
Ja, brauchen wir jetzt nicht lange drüber reden.
Also, ich mein,
ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob man das
so explizit herausheben muss,
weil, okay, er hat ja große Zähne
und er war kein Fan der Zahnbürste,
er hat ab und zu genascht und da sollen wir ihn jetzt Jahrtausende später noch dafür verurteilen. Ja und ich verstehe jetzt auch nicht, ich meine, was wollt ihr denn, wollt ihr dann, was ist denn der Umgestoß? Wo wollt ihr hin mit dieser Schnieren-Hetz-Kampagne, was ist euer Ziel? Wollt ihr jetzt irgendwie Zahnbürsten für T-Rex oder so eine Kampagne starten oder so? Ja, kommt da wieder dieses Almex-Männchen um die Ecke, ist das jetzt eine Marketingkampagne, wirft aber natürlich auch ein anderes Licht auf das furchteinflößende Röhren und Brüllen des T-Rex, weil vielleicht hat er einfach Au, Aua, Aua, heilte es durch die prähistorische Welt. Wobei das Nervige ist auch, weil wenn du das in den Zähnen hast, kennt man ja, auch gerade, und jetzt gerade, wenn man Fleisch gegessen hat, kannst du jetzt nicht mehr so richtig die Fasern, die Faszien, aber wenn du mal so eine schöne Salami beißt, danach hast du so Fasern in den Zähnen. So, und dann ist er nicht schöner, als es sich rauszuholen. So, und jetzt stell dir mal den T-Rex vor, mit seinen ganz kleinen Ärmchen.
Er hat zwar schöne Krallen, die lächerlicherweise, und da hat ihm die Ironie schon Lips durch die Rechnung gesprallert. Zu lange Stange, Stefan, warum? Nimm die kurze. Und jetzt verstehe ich nicht genau, warum das die Schicksale mit ihm so vorhatte, weil die Krallen wären ja perfekt gewesen, um die Fasern da rauszuholen, aber die Armlänge reicht nicht aus. Ja, deswegen brauchst du Timo, du musst dich mit dem anderen T-Rex zusammentun und der eine kann dir das aus den Zähnen kratzen, aber es ist grosses Vertrauensbeweis. Auch er hat sich kleine Hände. Kleine Leiter. Stein, geh auf den Stein hinauf. Aber ja, tut uns leid zu hören, ist natürlich ungünstig, so mit grosser Schmerz und ich weiß nicht, was man dagegen hätte tun können, Zahnseide oder sowas in der Richtung, aber vielleicht ist er auch nicht hinter Feinden, hinter Fressopfern hinterher gelaufen, sondern einfach, es war mehr so ein Missverstandenes Hey, kannst du mir kurz, hey, warum läufst du denn weg, kannst du mir kurz, ich hab was zwischen dem Zettel, hey, warum läufst du denn nicht, ach, ja, Aua, mein Zahn! Also der T-Rex, wir halten fest, nachdem er gequakt hat, Federn hat und lustige graue Härchen, war ja auch noch ein weinerliches Zahnschmerzenopfer, was sie nicht die Zähne gepusst hat. Die Schlagzeile titelt hier Morgens uronal abends Elrex. Na so. Würdet ihr das ins Gesicht sagen, was die Journalie hier wieder vorbringt, sicher hinter ihrem Schreibtisch im dreizehnten Stock.
Es klingt ja fast, als ob die beruhigt wären, wenn die mal irgendwann so eine
riesen Zahnbürste fänden in der Nähe
von so einem T-Rex-Skelett.
So, wo ich mich frage, was ist euer Ziel?
Wo wollt ihr da hin?
Ich glaube, das ist ein großer Marketing-Coup,
damals wie der Leibniz-Keks oder so,
wo ein großer Skandal geschaffen werden soll
und am Ende heißt es, damit nicht
auch du Zahnschmerzen hast wie ein T-Rex, kommt jetzt unsere Dinosaurier-Creme. So was. Hier, zum Beispiel. Ganz einfach. Verschiedene Dinosaurier als Zahnbürsten. Easy. Du hast den T-Rex mit so einem Irokesenschnitt, Zahnbürste und Borsten obendrauf. Ach so, du meinst, unten die Bürste ist der Kopf. Ja, zum Beispiel. Du hast ein ganzes Set. Also ich denke jetzt, zu welchem Produkt führt das hin? Da, wo das Federkleid wäre. Ja, da, wo die Sandalen wären. Genau. Beim T-Rex. Da ist die Zahnbürste oder halt dann Triceratops mit verschiedenen Zahnbürsten, Zahnseiden. Ja, du hast so ein Team. Ja, Triceratops, zwischen den Hörnern hast du die Zahnseide, die da so gespannt ist, damit hast du ein komplettes Set. So, und dann hast du halt noch so Zahncreme, die dazu passt, mit Blättergeschmack oder was weiß ich, was sie gegessen haben. Und das ist das Produkt, auf das diese Marketing-Heads-Kampagne hinsteuert, glaube ich, ist meine Vermutung. Hast du eigentlich mal alle 13 Filme von In einem Land vor unserer Zeit geguckt? Nein, ich habe einen, wir reden von Littlefoot, ne? Wir reden von Littlefoot, Sarah und Petri hat gefliegt. Nein, ich habe einen, ich kenne das Video von Jenny Nicholson, die alle angeschaut und rezensiert hat, kann ich euch sehr empfehlen. Die scheinen recht repetitiv zu sein und merkwürdig teilweise, weil das ist ja auch so ein Funfact, den ich letztens erst gelernt habe, es gibt ja zu jedem Filme Klassiker noch zehn weitere.
Genau. Ihr mögt Shrek, es gibt zehn Shrek-Filme, ihr mögt Toy Story, es gibt zehn Toy Story-Filme, Kurzfilme, Langfilme, Musicals, gibt's alles, aber das kennt niemand.
Problem ist nur, ihr mögt eine Sache, hier habt ihr zehn davon in Scheiße, hier habt ihr zehn davon, wo wir dachten, dass wir das nehmen, was euch gefällt und überzeichnen es. Es ist ein sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr, sehrer Pirat in Kacke. Das ist halt nicht so geil, wie es da läuft. Aber ich habe auch immer überlegt, die vielleicht nochmal zu gucken, weil ich war damals großer Fan davon. Und ich erinnere mich auch daran, dass es immer das Gleiche war. Also es ging immer darum, dass manche Dinos ausgegrenzt wurden, weil die anders waren als andere. Also da gab es so Bandenkriege, so Racism-Metaphern. Ja, genau. Und dann gab es immer einen Bösewicht, der hinter den Herr war. Lustigerweise wurden auch die Kids-Dinos immer von den Erwachsenen-Dinos getrennt. Und alles war so endzeitmäßig. Ich erinnere mich an sehr viel Lava. Diese Rassismus-Metapher hat dann aber auch immer so ihre Grenzen, weil ja, okay, die Langhälse und die Schafzähne, die ärgern sich und am Ende des Films ist man sich einig, dass die eigentlich doch zusammengehören und wir sind alle Dinosaurier. Aber die Hyänen sind trotzdem scheiße, da sind wir uns völlig
einig. Also die werden trotzdem noch gejagt
und sind unsere Feinde. Also klar, wir Dinosaurier
halten zusammen, aber es gibt immer noch
diese scheiß Säugetiere und die Raptoren,
die sind definitiv raus.
Also es gibt immer Grenzen, es ist immer nur so
ein, wir als In-Group gehen
näher zusammen, aber es gibt definitiv
eine Out-Group, aber definitiv.
Da wird überhaupt nicht drüber geredet. Ja, das stimmt schon. Aber ich meine, was kannst du denn sagen? Du kannst ja auch Das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ich mir auch. Da könnte jetzt noch so lange irgendwie Abenteuer gemeinsam bestehen. Am Endeffekt werde ich dich ja trotzdem fressen, Littlefoot. Macht das einfach mal, mach einfach mal einen Littlefoot-Marathon. Ich habe für mich jetzt auch wieder entdeckt, das sogenannte, ich habe das sogenannte Netflix-Scrollen. Und zwar Netflix besticht dir durch einen relativ ausgefeilten Algorithmus, zeigt dir immer an, genau was für dich gut sein könnte. Ich sage aber nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, nein, ich will nach ganz unten. Ich will scrollen, ich will scrollen, ich will nach ganz, ganz unten. Und ihr glaubt gar nicht, welche Perlen man finden kann, wenn man mal über die ganzen Jugendlichen neben Drogen Mainstream Serien rausgekommen ist, wenn man wirklich mal scrollt und vor allem ganz interessant auch ausländische Serien. Ich habe für mich entdeckt, Pui Pui Molka ist eine japanische Kinderserie.
Und das glaube ich, wird dir gefallen, weil sie hat eine ganz klare, präzise Prämisse, die dann ausgearbeitet wird. Okay. Und das ist ganz simpel. Die Prämisse lautet ganz einfach. Ist es eine animierte Serie? Es ist eine Stop-Motion-Serie. Okay. Also so wie Wallace & Gromit, so Knetfiguren und so, da sind es eher so fällige Wattefiguren. Und die Prämisse ist ganz einfach. Autos sind Meerschweinchen. Autos sind Meerschweinchen. Ja. Moment, Moment. Sind Meerschweinchen Autos oder Autos Meerschweinchen? Das war es schon, Stefan, wir sind schon am Ende. Wir sind schon angekommen. Wie? Die Prämisse lautet, Autos sind Meerschweinchen. Nee, weil du meinst so, dass Menschen fahren auf Meerschweinchen durch die Welt? Das ist schon vorbei. Nee, ich habe aber noch eine Frage. Das ist die gesamte Prämisse. Das ist der Pitch. Sie können hier nicht reinlaufen und ihre Serie Pitch. Sie können jetzt 100 Millionen Dollar investieren, ja oder nein, zu diesem Pitch, zu der Serie. Ich habe eine Rückfrage. Es gibt keine Rückfrage. Die Antwort wird immer lauten, Autos sind Meerschweinchen. Es wird immer dieselbe Antwort sein. Was ich mir gerade frage, können Sie sich mal kurz
einmal zurücknehmen, fahren
Menschen auf
Meerschweinchen durch die Straße oder
haben
Menschen in ihren Käfigen zu Hause
kleine Autos? Das möchte ich nur fragen.
Ich habe nicht gesagt, Meerschweinchen sind Autos,
ich habe gesagt, Autos sind Meerschweinchen.
Also alle Autos werden zu Meerschweinchen.
Korrekt. Also fahren Menschen auf Meerschweinchen durch die Strassen. Auf? Man fährt doch nicht auf sein Auto. Oh mein Gott, what the fuck? Man lässt sich fressen in Meerschweinchen, fahren durch die Gegend. Und es ist fantastisch, es ist grossartig, weil... Wie heißt die Serie nochmal? Die Serie heißt Pui Pui Molka. Und was heißt das? Keine Ahnung, ich will es auch nicht wissen. Es ist wirklich abgefahren und ich kann dir hier mal einen kurzen Ausschnitt zeigen, es ist wirklich wahnsinnig, es ist einfach wahnsinnig und wir sehen diese Autos. Wir sehen Menschen mit Sturmmasken und Waffen erstmal, es ist ganz anders, als ich mir das vorgestellt habe. Und also wir haben diese Meerschweinchen auf, die sind so wie Watte gebaut und wir sind eigentlich eher auf der Meerschweinchen-Auto-Ebene als auf der Menschenebene. Aber sie haben trotzdem Reifen. Sie haben trotzdem Reifen, laufen aber wie Meerschweinchen. Und diese Prämisse wird ganz präzise durchgearbeitet. Anstatt dein Auto zu tanken, gibst du deinem Auto ein riesiges Salatblatt. Klar. Weil es ist ja ein Meerschweinchen. Ja. So. Und es gibt schon auch Menschen, aber die sind eher so die Nebenfiguren. Und es ist ultra strange, es ist eine japanische Serie,
aber du musst nicht japanisch können, weil es wird nicht gesprochen.
Und es ist wirklich unglaublich. Mir gefällt vor allem, dass es Menschen gibt und die von Menschen gespielt werden,
in das Outdoor Angst.
Outdoor Angst vor den Menschen, die da hinlaufen.
Und wenn man sie in so Establer, so Totalen sieht, sind es Knetfiguren, so Actionfiguren, und wenn man sie nahe sieht, spielen es echte Menschen. Ja, genau. Es ist total absurd und es ist grossartig und ich glaube, man kann sich da in einem Fiebertraum wiederfinden, aber es ist auf jeden Fall eine tolle Serie. Meine Empfehlung Pui Pui Molka, falls ihr einfach mal wissen wollt, was geht denn eigentlich? Will ich die nächste Coming-of-Age, ja, man hat persönliche Probleme, Serien sehen, die nächste irgendeine wehre Fantasy-Story, wo fünf Fragmente von irgendeinem Amulett gefunden werden? Nein, Autos sind Märtschweinchen. Das ist es, das ist es. Also ich wünsche euch damit viel Spaß, ist vielleicht der neue Weihnachtsklassiker in vielen Familien jetzt. Kann ich einfach mal empfehlen.
Es erinnert mich ein bisschen daran, dass damals unsere erste Netflix-Ansprechpartnerin gesagt hat, ah, ist krass, wir explodieren gerade in alle Länder und so und es ist super spannend, wir kriegen von allen Ländern mega die coolen Konzepte auf den Tisch und einfach eine coole Zeit, in der wir gerade leben, perfekte Sachen und es ist so crazy, ausserwiegend in jedem Land gibt es spannende Sujets und coole Geschichten, mit denen man was anfangen kann. Außer aus Japan. Alle Konzepte aus Japan, verstehe ich nicht, ergeben keinen Sinn, sind weird. Man weiss nicht, ist es eine Show, ist das eine Serie, ist es Live-Action, ist es ein Prank, ist das Konzept ein Prank, das Konzept ist Watte, what the fuck is happening? Und ich versteh's ein bisschen, Pui Pui Molka, Autos sind Meerschweinchen. Versteh ich schon, ehrlich gesagt, dass man da erst mal ... Was gibt's denn daran nicht zu verstehen? Das kann auch jeder verstehen, das ist eine super simple Prämisse. Ja, ja, also man hat auch jetzt nicht zur Prämisse eine Frage, man hat viele Fragen, für wen ist das, wer ist die Zielgruppe, weil das ist ja ehrlich gesagt sehr, sehr, es gab Waffen und Männer mit Sturmhauben. Ja, es ist wirklich vollgetrieben. Und das Autor hatte, mehr schweinlich ein Story, Pardon, hat richtig Angst, es sah jetzt nicht so aus wie eine Kinderserie. Ja, ich weiß es nicht, aber es ist auch schon witzig gemacht, also es nimmt sich auch nicht sehr ernst und es ist grossartig. Ich finde es eine ganz tolle Mischung, aber es ist halt schon ein bisschen merkwürdig. Man fragt sich schon, warum existiert das? Ist das nötig? Es ist wirklich wie Rick and Mortys Interdimensional TV. Ja, im Grunde. Und das ist das Tolle so, weil das, glaube ich, findet man auch nur, wenn man ein paar Mal scrollt auf Netflix, wirklich so ganz runter. Und da kommen teilweise Juwelen zum Vorschein, das ist fantastisch. So, wo vorher noch ist, Schaus zu Ende, Unsere Tipps, Award-winning und du sagst, nee, nee, runter, runter, runter. Und irgendwann so, ach, ich glaub nicht, dass das was für dich ist. Und dann die Kategorien werden immer weirder. Pop-up, wollen sie nicht wieder hochscrollen? Wollen sie nicht wieder hochkommen? Es wird immer schwerer zu scrollen. Immer schwerer zu scrollen und die Titel werden immer sperriger für die Kategorie, wo man da so durchscrollen kann. Nee, glaube ich nicht, dass was für dich ist. Nee, komm, du hast noch andere Sachen vor, geh doch zu Amazon Prime. Ich weiss, du denkst, du willst mal was Neues auswählen, aber glaub uns wirklich, das wird dir nicht gefallen. Hey, never change the running system. Schau doch lieber nochmal Arcane an, stattdessen, ist doch okay. Disney Plus ist jetzt auch nicht das Schlechteste. Schau nochmal Arcane. Es ist großartig, ich mag das ganz gern. Und natürlich schaue ich das jetzt auch nicht stundenlang. Aber einfach mal in diese kurzen anderen Welten reindippen. Warum denn nicht? Schade, dass du das so gesagt hast, dass du es nicht stundenlang schaust. Also ich habe gestern, es sind immer kurze Folgen. Und jede Folge ist, glaube ich, so ein paar Minuten einfach. Aber pro Netflix-Folge sind dann so vier, fünf davon. Da habe ich mir eine angeguckt. Ich glaube, einfach so abends so zum Mittagessen oder so zum Abendessen, wo du auch nicht denkst, so will ich das angucken? Ich weiß es gar nicht, kann es nicht beantworten, es läuft halt einfach. Aber ich finde es so lustig, wenn du bist eine Netflix-Redakteur und sagst dann mal einfach so, ja, das, Pulpul, Molka, habe ich nicht ganz verstanden, aber es ist das Zugänglichste von allen anderen Sachen, nehmen wir mal und dann sagen die so, ja, wir haben die erste Folge fertig und dann guckst du es an, das ist so zwei Minuten lang und man denkt, what the fuck? Aber weil, und dann, das stand doch da drin. Ja, ich habe das nicht so genau gelesen. Ich habe das nicht genau gelesen. Und ich stelle mir das so lustig vor, dass man da Sachen in Auftrag gibt und dann kommt halt was, es kommt halt dann mal irgendwas zurück. Ja, ich glaube, es ist auch toll, falls ihr Kinder habt oder so, schaut das gerne mal mit denen an, ich glaube, ihr lernt was. Und ich glaube, eh ist es gut, einfach mit verschiedenen kulturellen Einflüssen zu arbeiten und einfach aus verschiedenen Ländern, weil Kinderserien kannst ja aus jedem Land gucken. So, in der Regel sprechen die nicht und du kannst dir einfach eine usbekische Kinderserie dir angucken, so wenn die einfach nur so rum, Tiere die halt miauen.
Na ja, schaut mal vorher, ob dieses Land irgendwelche ideologischen Probleme hat oder irgendwie frauenverachtende Meerschweinchen ziehen durch die Strassen.
So, das weiss ich nicht, ob das jetzt sein muss. Also guckt mal vorher, woher das kommt. Ja, da muss man natürlich vorher schon mal drüber gucken.
Bei Japan ist man ja erstmal safe, ob das jetzt sein muss. Also guckt mal vorher, woher das kommt. Ja, da muss man natürlich vorher schon mal drüber gucken.
Bei Japan ist man ja erst mal safe, glaube ich, so rein moralisch.
Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass die Große anders, also ...
Man weiß es nicht, wie gesagt ...
Hier viele Fragen geht es an Japan.
Ich halte euch auf dem Laufenden, wenn ich die erste Staffel durch habe,
kann ich ja dann noch mal ein Review geben.
Staffel.
Aber guckt mal durch, es gibt einige Staffeln, ja.
Schaut das mal an als Weihnachtshit.
Ich will, dass Netflix sich fragt,
warum zur Hölle schauen alle Pui Pui
Molka gerade, was,
da müssen wir noch eine Staffel Auftrag geben.
Weiß ich nicht, oder ist es so Anthology-mäßig,
dass Staffel zwei
dann so ist, dass Flugzeuge
Biber sind. Ah ja, genau,
das kann auch sein, das finde ich eine gute Idee.
Vielleicht jetzt so Black Mirror-artig, in dem Fall aber eine Staff Staffel zieht sich halt durch mit dieser Meerschweinchen-Premisse. Irgendwie bei der dritten Staffel haben sie mich verloren. Dachse sind Fahrräder, das hat dann für mich überhaupt nicht mehr funktioniert. Aber mal gucken, wie Staffel vier wird. Sind Meerschweinchen ein grosses Thing noch? Ich habe das Gefühl, die waren mal allgegenwärtiger. Ja, habe ich auch das Gefühl, das sind so Hyptiere auch, glaube ich, und der Hype flaut, glaube ich, ab. So eine ganze, vielleicht tun die sich auch zusammen und sagen, was können wir machen, damit wir wieder beliebter werden. Ich finde die ja unglaublich süss. Nachteil auch dabei ist, und das kann man vielleicht wegzüchten, dass die so in Käfigen sein müssen, riechen auch leicht, und dann diese mit diesen Käfigen und so. Ich meine, kann man das nicht so züchten, dass man die einfach so in der Wohnung hat? Und die kommen schon klar mässig und machen auch nicht viel Dreck. Und so, dass man die, weil das ist doch die Zukunft, dass man so Tiere hat, die so super pflegeleicht sind und einfach süss, süße Kuschelwesen, die durch deine Wohnung spazieren.
Ja, auch Otter, Dachse, sowas in der Ecke.
Und die ernähren sich nämlich von Staub.
Rättchen.
Staub. die legeleicht sind und einfach süss. Süße Kuschelwesen, die durch deine Wohnung spazieren.
Ja, auch Otter, Dachse, sowas in der Ecke.
Und die ernähren sich nämlich von Staub.
Staub ist nämlich deren Ernährung.
Die essen Dreck und Staub dir weg vom Boden, was so runterfällt.
Da überleben die und was sie ausscheiden hinten ist wie so Spüli oder so Parkettreiniger mässig.
Dahin müsste man mal züchten und dann hat man einfach so süße kleine Wesen, Flauschwesen.
Ideal eigentlich.
Ist total geil und dann laufen die so rum und jeder hat die zu Hause, wie so ein Staubsaugerroboter oder ein Staubsauger und dann so zu Hause so Dinger rumlaufen und dann hast du Namen, gibst du denen.
Ich denk's mir eh so, ob nicht die Technik am Ende ihrer Fähigkeiten ist und noch die Biologie eingreifen kann. Also wie gesagt, statt das neue Auto, wir züchten ein Greifen oder jetzt mal einfach nur in die Tüte gesprochen, auf dem wir durch die Gegend fliegen können oder sowas. Statt diesen Staubsauger-Robotern, lass uns halt irgendwie ein Frettchen züchten, das halt ein Staub braucht so. Oder halt das Fell wie so ein Swiffer, so dass das Fell von dem Frettchen halt das Staub auffängt. Das ich, deswegen mehr schweichert das ja ideal. Die sind ja auch schon wie kleine Swiffer. Und dass die halt instinktmässig sich immer in kleine Ecken reinzwängen, so Fluchtangst, dass sie ja richtig viel Angst haben den ganzen Tag. Und Zahnschmerz. Und sich immer in die Ecken verziehen, da wo ganz viel Staub ist. Und dann braucht man halt noch, dass die halt einmal am Tag irgendwie duschen oder so, dass sie halt den Staub abwaschen von sich, sowas in der Ecke. Sowas finde ich super. Das kriegt man auch mal hin, alle Genetiker da draußen, alle Biologen, bitte kurz aufschreiben. Genetiker? Aufhorchen bitte, züchtet das mal so kleine Putztiere, die einem die Wohnung sauber machen. Warum denn nicht? Es gibt ja schon, man sagt ja schon, man hat eine Katze, damit am Bauernhof irgendwie die Ratten gefressen werden oder so. Gutes Konzept, warum vor dreitausend Jahren aufhören, hallo, weiter geht's, nächstes Problem, nächstes Tier, nächste Züchtung. Ja, was ist los? Hallo, hallo, ich habe das Gefühl, manchmal die schlafen da schon wieder. Nee, ich glaube, die Schwerpunkte sind falsch. Ich glaube, die Wissenschaft hat sich auf falsche Sachen konzentriert. Auf Fleisch, oder wie? Fleischproduktion. Ja, sowas. Möglichst viele Flügel, Hühner mit fünf Flügeln, damit man ganz viele Chicken Wings haben kann. Ja, oder jetzt auch, keine Ahnung, ich glaube, man muss sich einfach ein bisschen verrannt. Also jetzt mal weniger auf Akkus oder so wertlegen, sondern mal auf so Gen-Shit. Ja. Oder mal, keine Ahnung, dass uns Flügel wachsen oder sowas. Da muss doch mal mehr gehen. Fünf Prozent unserer Einnahmen von unseren Duftkerzen, von unseren T-Rex-Zahnbürsten und von unseren 17 Apps gehen in einen Fonds. Und dieser Fonds wird der Tierfonds, mit dem wir dann neue Tiere basteln. Aber jetzt mal ganz ehrlich, ich bin auch ein bisschen enttäuscht von Diktaturen. Ja. Jetzt sagst du was jetzt. Ganz ehrlich, weil das ist ja deren Aufgabe, mal so jetzt mal einen Scheiss ausprobieren, mässige Dinge zu machen. So, weil das können wir nicht, weil wir haben Regeln. Aber jetzt so ein Kim Jong-un könnte ja sagen, so wir züchten jetzt mal so riesige Vögel und dann amportieren wir diese riesen Flügel mal in den Menschen rein. Wir würde ja erstmal niemand widersprechen und sagt, ja, großer Gottgegebener Meister, das machen wir. Okay, weil ich würde gerne mal sehen und klar stirbt der Erste dabei. That's fine. Lass uns das mal ausprobieren, bis dann einer nicht stirbt und der fliegt dann einmal mal rum. Aber wird dann nicht der der neue Gott? Oder was ist, wenn der wegfliegt und den will nicht unter Kontrolle haben? Nee, nee, nee, nee. Der kriegt auch einen hohen, guten Posten und so. Ich meine, wir können ihn ja auch nicht besiegen. Auch ein geiler Film, ehrlich gesagt. Kim Jong-un macht sowas und züchtet so aus Versehen so eine Superheldenarmee. Und dann wird Nordkorea plötzlich sehr stark. Ja, oder die übernehmen, die machen dann Putsch und übernehmen dann das Land selber wieder. Und dann gibt es so eine Superhelden-Marvel-Land, so Disneylandartiges. Man verdient das meiste Geld durch Popcorn, nicht durch die Einrittspreise, sondern durch Popcorn. Aber weißt du, das hat Kim Jong-Un halt nicht gemacht. Ja, ja. Und das ist irgendwie auch, finde ich dann, ich meine, Diktatoren können ja schon auch machen, was sie wollen. Das ist ja schon die Idee. Ja, absolut. Aber ich finde, die haben so ein paar Pflichten, haben die auch. Nämlich das darum zu probieren, wo man jetzt eher sagen müsste als Demokratie, na, können wir nie machen. Ja, stimmt. Ich meine, zum Beispiel in der SS gab es ja auch die Wünschelroutenabteilung. So, da gab es Leute, die haben den ganzen Tag gewünschelroutet und nach Gold gesucht, keine Ahnung, wonach man sucht, nach alten germanischen Artefakten. Und die hatten halt auch eine Abteilung, wo auch Leute wahrscheinlich gesagt haben, wo arbeitest du? Wünschelroutenabteilung. Und was? Aber das machst du ja selber mit dem Mund, das Geräusch. Ja, ich wollte es nur nachmachen, die Klänge. So klingt eine Wünschel, habt ihr da moderne neue? Aber du machst es ja selber noch, ich sehe das ja. Wir haben so große, du kennst ja Wünschelruten mit Holz, Holzäste, die vorne so auseinander gehen. Okay, macht mal. Viel Spaß im Krieg, viel Spaß im Krieg. Wir laufen rum. Kann ich mich versetzen lassen in die Wünschelrouten? Wir sind voll. Wirklich? Weil ich hätte noch viele im Garten und so. Blöd. Du bist Praktikant und wirst so, wo komme ich hin? Waffen-SS zu den Panzern? Nee, du bist Praktikant bei der Wünschelroutenabteilung. Das ist doch auch eine Serie, oder? Klar, natürlich, man muss aufpassen, aber schwarzer Humor, naja, das ist eine Gratwanderung, aber ich finde schwarzer Humor zu sagen, die SS-Wünschelroutenabteilung, da wirklich auch dann mit dem Leiter und mit den Projekten und wir müssen was liefern, Ergebnisse, habt ihr was gefunden? Das ist schon eine geile Serie. War denn ein Großelternteil von euch in der Wünschelroutenabteilung? Oh, das ist schon nicht schlecht. Weil ich höre immer das Gleiche, bin ich ganz ehrlich. Ich höre immer so Versorgungswägen, ich höre nie, oh mein Opa hat Leute umgebracht. Mein Opa hat auf der falschen Seite der Geschichte jemals gekämpft und Leute umgebracht. Nie gehört. Ich höre immer nur Versorgungswagen, Funk, Shit. Ja. Wo sind denn erstens, wo sind die Leute, die Wünsche der Routen hatten und das Bärnschens immer gesucht haben? Ja, stimmt, weil es gab ja zum Beispiel auch so einen SS-Reiter-Club und nach dem Krieg hatten ja viele Leute das Problem, dass sie halt dann in der SS waren und auch diese Tätowierung hatten, diese SS-Tätowierung, und dann erklären mussten, was sie gemacht haben. Und viele haben behauptet, sie waren nur in diesem Reiter-Club drin, so dieser ganze Krieg, und die Ideologie interessiert die gar nicht. Ich mag halt nur Pferde reiten. Warum haben sie dann kein Pferd tätowiert? Warum sie dann kein Pferd tätowiert haben? Naja, ich habe auch nur begrenzt Platz, so also auf meinem Körper. Das ist ja auch, muss man gucken, wie man klarkommt. Und ich glaube, in den Nürnberger Prozessen hat das tatsächlich auch eine Rolle gespielt, ab wann wer in welchem Teil von welcher Institution war. Und viele haben sich auf diesen Reiterklub gestürzt, der plötzlich wahnsinnig beliebt war. Ja, damals wurden die Leute ausgelacht, ihm mit euren Pferden, wir haben Panzer hier, ihr mit den scheiß Pferden,
aber nach dem Krieg, da wollen sie
alle in unserem Club gewesen sein, ich kann
euch das Register zeigen, niemand war da dabei.
Und das ist eigentlich auch interessant,
mit diesem Wünschelruten-Club, der auch so
verlacht ist, aber nach dem Krieg plötzlich
kommen sie alle an und wollen alle im Wünschelruten-Club
sein und alle so,
nee, ich finde das total spannend mit
Wasseradern und das ist super spannend, Schakren und so. Auch die einzige Abteilung, die fein raus ist, nachher bei den Nürnberger Prozessen. Ja genau, Freispruch auf allen Ebenen, weil ihr seid Vollidioten einfach. Vollidioten, die nichts gemacht haben. Die da auch reinkommen in den Gerichtssaal und erstmal schön die Energie und das Fingenschwehe abtasten. Und den Raum so sagen, die Ecken des Raumes mit so Weihrauch erstmal weg. Und der Richter auch so, oh Gott, hier kommen die voll. Holy shit. Aber das ist doch, ich glaube, das könnte eine interessante Serie sein. Soll ich das mal pitchen? Pitch mal. Pitch mal jetzt. Also, die Serie ist, wir schauen mal rein, haben Sie sich nicht schon mal gefragt, was in der SS-Wünschelrutenabteilung stattfindet? Diese rhetorischen Fragen finde ich gar nicht gut. Okay, lass die raus, lass die raus. 1939, die Welt versinkt im Krieg, ganz Deutschland ist in Aufruhr, die Welt zittert vor Angst, doch eine kleine Gruppe hat etwas anderes vor.
Ja, ja, ja.
Nämlich die SS-Wünschel-Routen-Abteilung.
Problem ist,
ich weiß, worauf Sie hinaus wollen,
wir haben jetzt gerade unsere Zahlen gecheckt
und wir haben gesehen,
dass ein Franchise gerade
besonders beliebt ist und wir suchen eher sowas.
Okay, ich kann mich auch umbauen.
Doidoi Polka.
Wom geht's da? Meerschweinchen sind Autos. Okay. Und das ist gerade ein sehr beliebtes Franchise und deswegen wollen wir eigentlich mehr in sowas noch mal gehen. Okay, könnten Meerschweinchen Wünschelruten sein? Ja, ja, ja. Okay, ja, klar, alles klar. Okay, gut, alles klar. Hier sind 100 Millionen Euro. Dankeschön, wow, vielen Dank. Ja, mache ich ihn. Also wie lange soll eine Folge sein? Zwei Minuten. Okay, klar, kein Problem, überhaupt nicht. Mache ich ihn 100 Stück? Überhaupt kein Problem. Super. Ja, super interessant. Wir können hier noch ganz kurz, es gibt noch eine zweite Schlagzeile, die uns zugeschickt wurde, und zwar zum Thema T-Rex. Ich weiß,
ich versuche sie nicht direkt hintereinander vorzulesen, weil es sonst so hart wird, aber ich glaube, du hast dich
ein bisschen erholt, und zwar
T-Rex waren
sehr Bandscheibenvorfall anfällig.
Moment, ich dachte, es kommt was anderes,
weil ich habe noch eine andere Schlagzeile
gelesen. Du kannst gleich noch eine dritte Anführung,
aber wir müssen es leider sagen, Bandscheibenvorfälle
waren
nicht unüblich unter
T-Rexen. Sie haben natürlich auch ein sehr
Aber Du kannst gleich noch eine dritte Anführung, aber wir müssen es leider sagen, Bandscheibenvorfälle waren nicht unüblich unter T-Rexen. Sie haben natürlich auch einen sehr gebeugten Gang, muss man auch sagen, die meisten T-Rexe sind nicht aufrecht gegangen. Weil die so sind, ja. Naja, aber warum sind die denn nicht aufrecht gegangen? Hä? Die können ja viel grösser sein, warum buuckeln die denn so? Weil die so ... das ist deren Idee ...
Versteh ich jetzt nicht.
Tatsächlich, als er das erste Mal entdeckt wurde,
hieß er ja auch Buckeldex.
Erst später wurde er im Tyrannosaurus Rex umbenannt.
Wer war der Kerl, oder Frau, die Tyrannosaurus gesagt hat ...
Einfach mal ...
Fuckin' cool.
Ich glaub, diese Leute embracen das Dino-Gain, wie wir das wollen. Tyrannosaurus Rex. Und wie heisst du? Biber. Okay. Ja, unterschiedliche Namen, ne? Biene. Biber. Hummel. Hummel. Ja, ehrlich gesagt, so und da... Es tut mir leid! So, und jetzt muss ich auch mal, jetzt bin ich mal sauer, weil eigentlich bin ich großer Fan gewesen von dem. Bandscheiben sind keine Erfindung der Säugetiere. Ja, nee, das wird jetzt. So sie analysen, widerliegen gängige Lehrmeinungen zu Bandscheibenlosen Sauriern. Überraschend anders. Wirklich? Vorlesen lassen. Ich finde auch so, bei den New Yorker zum Beispiel, der hat immer einfach tolle Sprecher, die das machen. Das will, ey, keine einzige fucking Folge. Just saying, fucking hell. Ja, aber das ist einfach besser, das ist einfach besserer Journalismus. Das ist einfach so gut, dass Stimmen, die das vorlesen. Ja, okay, gut, dann jetzt gib mir mal den T-Rex-Fact, lass uns das abschliessen hier. Ist ja furchtbar, wie die Träume platzen. So. Ich find's nicht mehr. Jedenfalls, das National History Museum in New York hat sich dieses Jahr Weihnachten überlegt, wir ziehen dem grossen Dinosaurier, den sie ja haben, den T-Rex, den habe ich auch fotografiert, ein ugly Weihnachtspulli an, ein ugly Weihnachtssweater. Und ich meine, das ist ein Naturkundemuseum. Man will die Knochen sehen, man will den T-Rex sehen, wie gross war der, wie furchteinflössend war der und die ziehen dem Weihnachtspulli an. Die ziehen dem so einen riesen Strickpulli an,
mit so schönen Tannenbäumchen und Weihnachtsmann drauf,
haben die den Arm nicht mehr angezogen.
Und dann bei Instagram war das so ein Riesenthema,
da haben die auch geschrieben,
how do you put a jumper on a T-Rex?
Und man nimmt die ganze Zeit so, nein, das ist keine Frage.
Nicht how, das ist nicht die Frage. Why the fuck, es macht keinen Sinn, ihr habt Probleme, die keine sind, ihr sucht Lösungen für Probleme, die nicht existieren, das ist Unsinn. Vor allem, was ist denn aus der guten alten Weihnachtsmannmütze geworden? Das ist ein gängiger Gag.
Setz dem eine Weihnachtsmann-Mütze auf, damit man seinen scheiss Pony, seinen Vertretungslehrer-Pony nicht sehen muss. So, aber nicht den Pulli. Nein, zieht dem T-Rex nichts an. So eine flotte Chino-Chino? Nein, keine Chino, keine, nicht so eine. Nein, ich glaub, Kleider machen Leute, man kann da was rausholen.
Mit so Flotten ...
Leg dem kein Tambourin in die Krallen
und stell dem keine Mundharmoniker in die Fresse.
Lass den Let him be.
Aber wir wissen ja nicht, was er anhatte.
My dear Americans.
Wir wissen ja nicht, was er anhatte.
Wahrscheinlich nichts.
Sein Federkleid.
Sein langes, buntes Federkleid, nichts anderes. Und ich verstehe nicht, warum die dem jetzt einen Ugly-Jumper anziehen müssen.
Ja, ich verstehe es auch nicht. Ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher. Warum, warum, also ich habe wirklich das Gefühl, das ist eine Kampagne, die ganz systematisch versucht, den T-Rex lächerlich und dumm dastehen zu lassen. Wir haben seit Jahren keine Schlagzeile mehr gelesen, wie T-Rex konnte VW Käfer zerbeissen, hat jetzt die Forschung rausgefunden. Oder T-Rex konnte zehn Liter Milch auf Eggs trinken, wenn er wollte. So geil! T-Rex hat Blut getrunken aus... Ja! T-Rex war manchmal auch bis nach Mitternacht wach. T-Rex hat getrunken wie ein Schlot. Ja, nichts davon. Stattdessen Bandscheiben, Zahnschmerzen, ugly Sweater, leicht ausser Atem, langsam, übergewichtig, Akne, lange Haare, lange fettige Pferdeschwanzhaare.
Weisse Haare. Was kommt denn da noch?
Scheiße. Das macht keinen Spaß mehr. Naja, das war jedenfalls die Kategorie.
Flotin, ich habe das Video-Update!
Again,
das haben wir aufgenommen, bevor wir wussten,
in welche Richtung das geht.
Ja. Scheiße.
Naja, gut. Es war nicht das Jahr des T-Rex, muss man ganz ehrlich sagen, es war nicht das Jahr des T-Rex. Die letzten fünf Jahre waren nicht das Jahr. Nee, wir haben Sinnbad in einem Tal. Aber hast du jetzt mit Blick auf Silvester das Gefühl, nächstes Jahr wird dein Jahr? Nee. Hattest du niemals das Gefühl, nächstes Jahr wird dein Jahr? Ich glaube, 2016 dachte ich. Ja, und? Das wird mein Jahr und es wurde nicht mein Jahr. Wurde 2017 nicht dein Jahr oder 2016 schon nicht? Nee, ich habe 2016 mir vorgenommen, dass 2017 mein Jahr werden würde. Was gab dir Anlass, das zu glauben? Ich habe es gefühlt, am Silvesterabend dachte ich, nee, jetzt geht es voran. Ach, erst am Silvesterabend. Ja, es war ein relativ spontaner Moment, wo ich mir dachte, jetzt, das ist mein Jahr, stimmt eigentlich. Ich habe mal rumgefragt, hat schon jemand das Jahr beansprucht? Nö wird es ich ja gut ne also wirklich wenn sonst jemand will weil ich voll 2020 weil es irgendwie schön ist ja okay geil ne dann würde ich jetzt 17 nehmen und dann wird das mein jahr 2017 wird mein jahr geht stein du musst nur hier einmal unterschreiben das ist diese jahresurkunde okay dann ab morgen ja ist das dann Gut, wunderbar, danke schön. Wurdest du dich nicht, warum niemand sonst 2017 wollte? Ach ja, du hattest ja 2004, glaube ich. Und der Rest? Ja, das war mein Jahr. Das war mein Jahr. Wieso, ist irgendwas nichts? Nee, nur, keine Ahnung, also irgendwie hat es keiner genommen und war irgendwie so unbeliebt und es ist Silvester und noch niemand hat 2017 als sein Jahr. Ja, ich habe es irgendwie gefühlt. Ich hab's im Gefühl und ich würde ab morgen direkt loslegen und mir das einfordern, einholen. Ich hab's an der Angel, ich hab's gefühlt, das Jahr zappelt an der Angel am Köder und ich muss es nur noch reinholen. Und ab morgen wird richtig gekurbelt. Und jeden Tag wird mehr gekurbelt, bis das Ding in meinem Boot liegt und ich ein paar schmackige Hiebel auf den Kopf, die unter die Kiemen dieses Jahres geben werde. Und ein Jahr später. Und? Erst mal cool, dass wir so eine Freundschaft haben, dass wir uns einmal im Jahr an Silvester sehen. Wie war dein Jahr? Richtig scheiße. Ich weiß es nicht. Also, falls, ganz kurz, könnt ihr Rückmeldung geben, falls es wirklich niemand von euch das nächste Jahr will, würde ich mich bereit erklären, dass es mein Jahr wird, aber ansonsten mal schauen. Ich würde sagen, ich gehe da entspannt rein. Also ich beantworte, das nächste Jahr ist nicht für mich. Okay, du lenkst dich zurück. Nächstes Jahr lenk ich mich zurück und guck mal was passiert.
Aber ich habe auch schon das Gefühl, dass es mein Jahr werden könnte.
Viele Projekte,
natürlich im Köcher, die als kannst du uns konkret was
zeigen?
Nein, ich lenk das ja so,
das sind immer alle, ich habe
nichts, aber diese ganze, aber
niemand hat irgendwas. Aber ich denke, das wirklich, niemand hat
irgendwas, aber alle immer so, wir können ja nicht drüber sprechen und so. Ganz ehrlich, wenn ihr das in der Medienlandschaft hört, ich kann ja nicht drüber sprechen, in 80 Prozent der Fälle können wir darüber sprechen. Ist es völlig okay zu sagen, dass man mit dem und dem arbeitet und so. Die wollen das dann nur nicht oder wollen sich wichtig machen. Jeder kann über alles sprechen. Und du so, ja, ja, ich habe einige Pläne. Und du schaust da auf deinen Zettel, Vampire sind Zucchini. Kann ich jetzt leider noch nicht drüber reden, das wird dann erst gross.
Oder meine Idee bedeutet Polka Staffel vier, Gurken sind Zucchinis. Und das ist mein Lieblingsuniversum. Kröten sind Frösche, so jetzt.
Oh, Alligatoren sind Krokodile, Holy, Alter! Wie soll ich das umsetzen? So die langweiligste Paralleldimension, die man sich vorstellen kann. Du fliegst in eine andere Dimension und das ist der einzige Unterschied. Gurken sind Zurinis. Ja, finde ich ganz gut. Aber ich glaube, das würde ich meinem Kind auch beibringen. Gurken und Zucchinis. Entweder umgedreht beibringen, ich würde Zucchinis immer Gurken nennen und andersrum, oder ich sage, dass es selten ist. Und bis er irgendwie dann so neunzehn ist oder sowas, kannst du mir kurz die Zuri Gurke geben? Ja, ich bin schwach. Ich bin schwach. Ich bin schwach. Ich kenne nichts. Massive psychische Probleme, einfach nur weil du als Vater geprankt hast
und einfach auch Himbeer und Kirsche einfach immer vertauscht hast.
Möchtest du nicht auf dem Tisch neben mir, Stuhl neben mir sitzen, Lisa, möchtest du nicht auf dem Tisch, Stuhl, reich mir bitte die Gabel, Messer, Struggle. Und als Vater sitzt man dann neben und denkt sich, ja das zweite Kind wieder normal oder das erste Kind einfach mal geopfert. Einfach dahin. Ja, Klementin sind Mandarinen. Ja, was? Ja, es gibt ja keine Mandarinen mehr, aber man sagt immer noch Mandarinen. Also jetzt, wie wir alle kennen, Weihnachtszeit ist für mich eigentlich die, wenn man konstant Hände hat, die nach Mandarinen riechen, immer ein bisschen was von der Mandarinschale unter den Fingernägeln hat und diese weissen Fasern überall in der Wohnung. Was sind Orangen?
Orangen sind orange Obstknollen, die wachsen an Orangenbäumen und sind fruchtbar und lecker.
Was sind Pampelmusen?
Pampelmusen sind ein Zwischending zwischen Zitronen und Orangen. Echt? Was sind Klementinen? Klementinen sind der hässliche Stiefbruder der Mandarine, der aber langsam das Hoheitsgebiet der Mandarine übernimmt und niemand merkt es und niemand spricht darüber. Das heißt, was wir essen sind Klementinen, nicht Mandarinen. Aber man sagt meistens noch Mandarinen. Mandarinen sind weg. Sind raus. Man verdrängt von der Klementine. Granatabfüll ist was ganz anderes. Niemand versteht Granatabfüll, niemand versteht, was der soll, warum sich jemand die Mühe macht, den aufzupacken, weiß niemand.
Grapefruit? Ja. Es ist ein bisschen sowas wie eine schlechte Orange.
Ist eine Grapefruit nur Blutorange? Nein. Das ist wieder was anderes.
Das ist alles was anderes. Ich dachte, ich habe gar keine Ahnung von... Wenn die Wörter anders sind, sind das, was die Wörter beschreiben, auch anders.
Nee, nee, nee, nee, nee. Also seltener.
Der Moon ist der Mond. Das ist immer eine andere Sprache, das ist immer was anderes.
Nee, aber Grapefruit ist ja eine andere Sprache als Blutorange. Nee, das ist auch ein deutsches Wort. Grapefruit ist ein deutsches Wort. Grapefruit ist ein deutsches Wort. Es gibt kein deutsches Wort dafür. Das glaube ich nicht. Natürlich ist es deutsches Wort. Aber du hast mehr Obstwissen als ich. Du bist da begabt. Aber auch nur leicht. Ich meine, du hast eine Fünf, ich habe eine Vier Minus. Also wir sind beide keine Experten, was das angeht. Oh, die Grapefruit ist der Adamsapfel. Was? Paradiesapfel. Genannt. Ernsthaft? Das ist eine Kreuzung aus der Orange und der Pampelmuse. Was ist denn hier los? Wenn dein zweiter Cousin mit meiner Neffin dann entsteht eine Grapefruit. Ist eine Kreuzung aus der ... Adamsapfel? Ja, genau, man nennt die Grapefruit, ist selten auch Adamsapfel oder Paradiesapfel genannt. So selten, so nah als so nie. Peter Schmidt aus Brückhorst ist die Frucht des Grapefruitbaumes. So, und das ist eine Kreuzung aus der Orange und der Pampelmuse. Die Pampelmuse wiederum ist eine Kreuzung aus der Orange und der Grapefruit. Das ist einfach immer ein Kreis. Und niemand weiß, wie das angefangen hat. Die Pampelmuse, größte Zitrone, ist ein immergrüner Baum, der die größten Zitrusfrüchte hervorbringt. Im Englischen Sprachen wird Pampelmuse als Pomelo oder Pumelo oder Shadok bezeichnet. Oder Shady, Shabler, Shabler oder Jimmy.
Die Pflanzen hat gehört zu den Rautengewächsen,
aber das interessiert ja gar nichts mehr.
Die Pampelmuse ist einfach die grösste Zitrone der Welt.
Die jeweils grössten Zitronen werden einfach Pampelmuse genannt.
Verschiedene Zitros sind durch die Kreuzung aus der Pampelmuse entstanden. Durch Kreuzung der Pampelmuse mit der Mandarine entstand die Orange. Okay. Also Pampelmuse und ... Ist der Grossvater. Pampelmuse ist quasi der Vater von allem. Ja. Denn Pampelmuse und Mandarine ergibt Orange. Das ist ja verrückt. Und jetzt, achte mal, und wenn man die Orange jetzt quasi den Sohn nochmal mit der Mutter Pampemuse kreuzt, also das ist ja wirklich Incest-Scheiße, entschied die Grapefruit. Ich will nicht sagen, dass ich es mir immer gedacht habe, aber ich dachte mir, die Grapefruit ist strange. Ich dachte mir, die Grapefruit ist irgendwas faul. Hallo. Das ist irgendwas komisch. Das ist ja interessant. Das wusste ich überhaupt nicht. Aber da könnte man doch ein schönes Printposter machen mit dem Stammbaum der Zitrusfrüchte. Das ist ein Kreis. Am Ende ist es ein Kreis, aber ich glaube, das ist auch ein flottes Printposter. Oder es ist eine Raute, deswegen Rauten gewechselt. Oh, das kann auch sein. Finde ich eine gute Idee. Druck das doch gerne mal auf dem Poster und verkauft es in eurem Shop. Ich würde eine nehmen. So in diesem alten Stil, du kennst diesen Stil, so alte Botaniker. Ich kenne den Stil. So Fick, Fick vier. Wie war der Gag mit der? Was? Feige. Ja, genau, ich glaube zwei Feigen und da Fick eins und Fick zwei ich war der Gag, aber ich weiss nicht mehr genau. Das ist aus dem Botaniker-Instagram, Botaniker-Gags, wo ich auch immer gern ablache.
Nee, ich hatte lange ein altes Schulplakat aus dem alten, ich glaube, Uni aus Berlin oder so, stand unten drauf.
So ein ganz altes Plakat, was man so aufmacht und dann hinhängen kann.
Und da hatte ich lange die Zauneidechse.
Fick eins, Zauneidechse, hatte ich bei mir beim Bett hängen. Hat den Umzug nicht überstanden, ich weiß nicht, wo sie ist. Einfach verbrannt, einfach irgendwo unter die Räder gekommen, ist einfach aus dem Truck gefallen. Die Zauneidechse ist irgendwie unter die Räder gekommen. Aber fand ich ganz cool, also sah cool aus. Ripp. Könnt ihr euch gerne auch mal besorgen, so schöne botanische Zeichnungen. Ich würde sagen, wir widmen diese Folge der Zauneidechse. Egal, wo sie ist, sie wird ja noch irgendwo sein. Vielleicht hängt sie bei euch mittlerweile. Zauneidechse, mach's gut. Mach's gut, wir vermissen dich, aber vielleicht sehen wir uns eines Tages wieder. Und wir sehen uns definitiv wieder, nämlich nächste Woche. Richtig, wir ballern einfach. Wir sind, glaub ich, die einzigen, die einfach durchballern, die vorhaben, durchzuballern. Auf jeden Fall weitermachen und wir hören uns, wir sehen uns definitiv wieder, nämlich nächste Woche. Richtig, wir ballern einfach. Zur neuen Folge, wir ballern durch. Wir sind, glaube ich, die einzigen, die einfach durchballern, die vorhaben, durchzuballern.
Kann sein, wir werden auf jeden Fall weitermachen und wir hören uns, wir sehen uns. Weil wir nichts zu tun haben.
Habt ihr Schöne.
Weil ich niemanden hab.
Weil Weihnachten, das war alles erfunden, kommt niemand, ich bin allein.
Okay.
Macht's gut, schöne Woche.
Alles klar, schöne Woche, macht's gut, ciao, wir heben ab.
Ja.
Zu Voice-Bug-Ratsch.